Everyone is so sexed up
on that show.
I mean, it's the hottest people-
Sure.
Yeah, the tension
looks palpable.
No, I'm sure people were sitting
at home jerking off
to that show, being like,
"Oh, she just said 'rough sex.'
That's disgusting! I'm watching
this with my children!"
But I love it.
Yeah, they do dances where like,
the girl just flips up
into his face
and rides around with her box
right in his face.
Literally, that is a move.
Yeah, just, come and get it.
Soup's on.
Doug Benson is with us.
You can see him tonight
at the 12 Guests
of Christmas
at the Gramercy Theater.
Also, December 2nd and 3rd
at Largo in Los Angeles.
He also has a show,
Getting Doug
With High, where he smokes weed
with comedians, and that's-
On YouTube, yeah.
On YouTube. It's super fun.
Adam's done it.
So fun. So baked.
Oh, Tom did it too!
Yeah, I did it too.
Adam has got to his audition
right now.
Can I tell you real quick
before, when I did your show,
literally the next morning
when I was doing
Mad TV,
we shot a sketch
where we were playing
potheads at 7:00 AM.
I was still so baked
from your show.
Oh, that's great.
It was kind of,
but then also terrible,
because I was just like ...
at first I got there.
I was like, "It'll be great,
because I'm still
really fucked up."
We're playing a show where we're
potheads doing a cooking show.
Yeah, it's easy to get too
fucked up to play fucked up.
Yeah and then we would start,
Amir K
and I would start improvising,
and he would just look at me,
and I was like ...
"Oh, was that not funny?"
He was like,
"Dude, you're fucked up."
I was like,
"Can we take ten?"
Oh, my God. We need-
I love Amir K at breakfast time.
Doug Benson is in the studio
with me and Tom Thakkar.
Hello.
Doug Benson, who I have been
a huge fan of
since Best Week Ever days.
Doug Benson used to steal
the show on Best Week Ever.
I'll never forget one line
that has stayed with me
since 2006, I remember,
probably 2005.
It was some story
about Paris Hilton,
and it was like,
she was leaving some place.
You were like, "Hey Paris,
don't let the door have sex
with you on the way out."
Still gets me.
I remember like, me and my
friends loved it so much.
Then I got on
Last Comic Standing
my senior year of ...
and Doug was like,
one of my favorite comedians.
I used to make lists,
I was so obsessed with comedy.
Doug was always on my list,
like my top favorite
comedians, still is.
Funniest, just one of
the funniest people ever.
Then I go
to Last Comic Standing,
my senior year I get passed
at the Chicago auditions,
and I go to LA
for the semi-finals,
and Doug Benson is
in the lobby
of the Hilton Garden Inn
in Glendale,
where they were putting us
during the show.
I go, "That's Doug Benson.
What is he doing here?"
I went up to go say,
"I'm a fan. I love you."
I go, "Why are you here?"
And he was like,
"I'm doing Last Comic Standing."
I'm like, "I'm competing
against you?
What is going on here?"
It was like me and
Tanashe,
pretty much,
is like how I felt.
Me meeting Alexis Ren
on the first day of Dancing
With the Stars.
I was like, "Why am I here?"
You do meet a lot of people
through doing these shows.
I met Tig that time too.
Yeah, who else was
on that season?
It was-
Was Todd on that one?
No, no. Todd was
on the very first one,
and then he was also
on that weird battle
of the first and second seasons
one that they did,
where they didn't announce
the winner on TV.
They just mentioned it during
an ad during an animated ...
It was the premiere
of a new animated show
that ended up bombing.
They mentioned it during
a break in another show.
That's nuts.
Who the winner was.
Who won that?
I think Alonzo Bodden.
Alonzo Bodden, that's right.
Yeah, there were a lot
of people there that season.
That was so fun.
Remember how they
sequestered us
when, we were at the point
where nobody had ...
there was like 40 comedians
were all going to compete
to see who makes it
into the next stage.
Top ten.
Yeah, so we had to stay
in a hotel room for ...
we were sequestered in a hotel
for a couple of days.
We had roommates.
Yeah, yeah. My roommate
was Chris Porter, who-
Mine was Jackie Kashian.
Who advanced, and then you still
have to stay there
one more night after they say
who advanced and who hasn't.
I had to be roommates
with a guy
who was celebrating
all night long,
because he had advanced
and I didn't make it.
That's what happened,
is I came back the next year,
and that's when I made it
into the next group.
That's where I met Amy Schumer,
and that's where
we became friends.
Yes.
Yeah, but the season
where you and I were there,
remember Sean Rouse
was there?
Yes.
He passed away recently.
I know.
Hilarious dude. They wouldn't
let us out at night,
and the bar closed at ten.
We wanted drinks,
so he figured out ...
they had somebody posted
at the front door of the hotel.
He ordered a pizza
from Domino's,
and when the guy got there
at the hotel room door, he said,
"Can I give you extra money
for your shirt and your hat?"
He bought the guys
shirt and hat,
and left the hotel like
he had just delivered pizzas.
Yeah.
That's how he got out.
Wait. What did he do
with the other guy?
The other guy wore his clothes.
He locked him in a closet?
Oh, I see.
No, they just switched clothes.
The idea was just get past
the Last Comic Standing
chaperone person.
Yeah.
That was watching the door.
He escaped out that way,
but then I met him at the bar,
because the hotel
had a back door.
I didn't have to go to such
elaborate lengths to get out.
Then we just went to a bar
nearby and drank for hours.
Yeah.
Yeah, it was a very strange
experience.
Josh Wolf was also ...
he was, we had like adjoining
doors between our rooms.
So, Chris Porter, I think it was
Ty Barnett, is that his name?
Yeah.
And Josh Wolf.
We just opened up
the adjoining door,
and the four of us would all
just smoke weed every night.
It's so funny how that show,
they try to control you,
but they don't, it's not
the same as other reality shows.
You can get away
with a lot of shit.
Me and Amy used to take,
when we'd have to go
and get on the small bus
to go to events and stuff,
we'd just fill a coffee cup
with booze at the hotel bar
and sit there drinking
out of it.
It looked like
we were drinking coffee.
Oh, yeah.
But vodka drips through,
it cuts through the paper.
Oh.
It starts to drip,
so you've got to drink it fast.
I didn't know that.
Yeah, that's weird.
Yeah. It's real weird,
because I put it in my body
all the time,
and then it eats through a cup.
I'm like,
"My liver can handle it.
My liver's stronger
than a cup."
Yeah.
That was the vibe,
when I came back
for the finale of Dancing
With the Stars.
Everyone's just drinking
and smoking in their trailers,
and before that,
because we have nothing to lose.
We're not trying to ...
the rules are
all still in place,
but no one's
following them anymore.
We're just, some of us aren't
showing up for dress rehearsal,
because we know we just have
to stand there and watch.
It was so much more fun.
I've told this before,
but when I got eliminated
from Last Comic Standing,
I was still in college.
I had to go back and do tests
and go back to class
the next week.
I was like,
"I don't want to go."
I was having a cigarette
with Brendan Walsh,
who also got eliminated
that night.
We were outside the Glendale
Hilton, and I was like,
"I don't want to go back
to school tomorrow."
He's like, "Just tell them
you're still on the show.
It's not going to air
until the summer,
so just tell them
you're still ..."
So, I just did.
I emailed them, and I said,
"I'm still on the show,
and I'm in LA."
They were like,
"Follow your dream girl!"
Then I just didn't have
to go back to school ever,
because then it was over,
and they never knew.
It was such a brilliant plan,
but ...
Some might be finding
out right now.
I'm sorry.
Thank you for believing in me.
Your class was worthless.
I didn't really learn anything
at the University of Kansas.
They're going to take
your degree away.
Then we did, shortly after that,
you started opening for me
on the road and stuff.
Yes, that was awesome.
That really took everything
to the next level,
and that's the only way
you can get to the next level
is having a headliner
take you to feature for them,
and then getting
that amount of stage
sense.
That was so rad.
I got in so many places
through you,
so many clubs
that I still work to this day.
First time going there was with
Doug Benson, so I always ...
I owe you a lot, Doug.
You were the first guy
to bring me on the road.
That means something,
because then other people
start bringing you on the road,
because then you get better
because someone took the chance.
I remember the first time
I opened for Doug,
I didn't have 20 minutes.
I was terrified,
but then you get it together,
because someone believes in you.
You have to.
It takes one person
to believe in you.
That's what Lady Gaga said
1600 times in an interview.
"If there's a room
of 100 people,
and 99 don't believe in you,
Doug Benson was the one
who believed in me.
Doug Benson was
that person for me."
So, thank you Doug.
Remember that show we did
at Morty's that one night?
Oh, God.
Where the entire audience was,
as they say, urban?
It was a black crowd,
because they gave away tickets
on the local urban
radio station.
No, I don't remember this.
I probably blacked it out.
Oh, my God. It did not go well.
Oh, no.
For anybody.
No.
Well, that club's over now.
Yeah, but the host was
a black guy and he killed.
Oh, right. Okay.
Then you had a hard time
after him,
and then I had a hard time
after both of you.
I had a lot of hard times
with you.
I was still new, and that's what
meant so much to me, that you-
You were working it out.
Anthony Jeselnik used to bomb
in front of me.
He'd walk people that would just
get up and leave,
like we're not even going
to stay for Doug Benson.
Right.
Because this guy's making us
so upset.
I learned so much
from Doug Benson on the road.
First of all, and things
that I still do on the road,
which is like, you like
everything just to be in or-
... you expect
a lot from clubs,
because it doesn't take much to
just deliver a good experience.
It's easy.
Really, it's so easy.
When they fuck it up,
it's really annoying.
I don't like it, and I don't
stand for it anymore.
I've seen how you handle
those situations,
and you'll go in and be like,
"Guys ..."
I just call out things,
like if my veggie tray
isn't there, I get annoyed,
because how hard is it
to get a fucking veggie tray?
Right. It's like-
It's the only thing I ask for.
I'm not asking
for a pair of new Nike's,
which some people are.
Yeah.
You have to go to Shnuck's
or ...
that's a grocery store
in St. Louis, but you know.
You have to get it
from Shnuck's in St. Louis.
It's not that hard
to put in an order.
That's why it's hard.
Did you ever see that movie,
Dinner for Shnuck's?
Also, another thing I learned
from you that I love,
and I don't know
if you still do this.
You would get off stage,
like you would be,
"I'm doing a 45 minute show,
maybe 50 minute,
and I don't need ..."
These guys that do hour
and a halves,
and like, what are you
hiding from off stage?
They never want
to get off stage.
What are you running
from in your life?
Exactly. When Dave Chapelle-
Who's calls would you have to
return if you got off stage?
Exactly. When Dane Cook
or all these ...
Carlos Mencia
used to do it.
He did 7 hours last night.
Why don't you want to go home?
It's a badge of honor.
But also, I want to go home.
Like, as an audience member,
show me my favorite comedian,
an hour and a half, I'm out.
And the staff, the wait staff
has to just serve cokes
or nothing after last call.
The comedian goes all night,
and they have to stay.
It sucks.
Brutal.
In case somebody at their table
wants another coke.
They're sitting
around all night,
and they're not getting tips
that reflect
the amount of time
they're spending there.
People in audiences
have such social anxiety
that they can't even go
to the bathroom during a show,
because they're worried
that the comedian is going
to call them out or everyone
in the room will look at them.
People are holding in their pee
the whole show already,
and then when you push that-
Yeah, it's a hostage situation.
-you're just putting people ...
it is a hostage situation.
A few people are enjoying it.
It's a social grace
hostage situation,
where it's like people
who are polite,
you're holding them hostage.
Yes, yes.
That's a great idea.
We should just take a break
at some point in the set.
Does anyone need
to use the restroom?
Raise your hand if you need
to use the restroom.
Okay, go ahead.
I'll look away.
I'm not going to say
anything about it.
I'll turn around.
I won't make fun of you.
I actively, when someone
stands up and you can tell ...
I actively turn the other way,
so they know-
Me too.
I hate that.
I can't help myself.
I always mention it,
but I try not to shame them
for having to use the bathroom.
I try to make it more on me,
like I always say
something like,
"Oh yeah, you're right.
This is a good time to get up."
Yeah, that's good.
Your senses are correct.
If it feels like something
that is not political
and they stand up,
I'm like,
"Oh, I'm sorry. I offended
the Korn fans," or whatever.
Oh, yes. There's little tricks
like that.
I think it's funny then,
but like in general,
I'm just like I know
that you probably have to shit.
You don't want to deal with me
right now making fun of you.
Yes.
Maybe not shit.
I don't know how often somebody
gets up during a show
to take a shit.
I assume everyone
in the audience is shitting.
I hate when a comedian calls
out a girl and is like,
"She's just going to shit."
"What are you doing?
Taking a dump?"
Oh, it's like-
"A big gnarly dump?"
She's on a date.
That's the last thing.
"Let's listen everybody."
Oh, yeah. We've all heard this.
I've seen a comic follow
somebody to the bathroom
and just stand outside the door
while they use the bathroom
and then wait.
That's harassment.
I know.
Getting Doug with High,
you've been doing that
show a while on YouTube.
Yeah, we just celebrated
our fifth anniversary.
Wow.
And we celebrated
by smoking some weed.
Hell yeah.
Dude. People that do that show
get so fucked up.
I had one of the worst days
of my life, was doing that show.
I have so many friends ...
what is it?
Is it because you're dabbing?
What is happening?
We dab at the end, but even
before we added that segment,
people were just ...
and me.
I definitely have, I try not to
have much to do after I do it.
It kind of ruins
the rest of the day,
because it's just ...
it's not just standing around
casually smoking
until you're high.
It's smoking until you're high,
and then you just kind of have
to push through and keep going.
Yeah, because
you're constantly going.
We're live for 45 minutes,
people just start calling you
a pussy in the comments.
That's it, yeah.
If you're not smoking
the whole time.
Oh, my God.
That was my fear,
is I didn't want to-
I really want to do it.
I get so ...
because I'm back
on the weed train.
Doug has asked me
to do it before,
and I'm like,
"I'm not smoking weed now,"
or I am but I don't want to be
public about it, or whatever.
Now I'm back on the weed train,
but like, I guess ...
do you still take breaks?
Do you still do Sober October,
that kind of thing?
I do, but I never take breaks
from weed. It's just alcohol.
I don't know that I need a break
from weed.
I feel very similar
to you with weed,
that like it makes me
work harder.
Do you feel like it's a
stimulant for you in a way?
You know, I smoke all day
every day,
and I manage to get
some things done.
You know, any time
you get really high,
you're either ...
you get ambitious,
but you might be
ambitious to do nothing.
You might be like,
"I'm really going to hunker down
and not get up right now."
You know?
If I don't have plans
throughout the day,
if I have a totally free day,
and the first thing
I do is get high,
then I'll spend
the next 3-4 hours
trying to figure out
what the fuck to do.
I end up not doing
anything productive.
It's like walking around
in a Blockbuster video store,
and then walking out
without picking a movie,
because you just
can't settle on anything.
Yes, but if you have a plan and
you get high, you can execute.
When I have stuff to do all day,
I can just get high in
between the things,
and just be high
and do the things I need to do.
That's sort of what props me up.
I joke around about how like,
I like to take pictures of fans
after the shows,
because they're holding me up.
Yes.
I put my arms around them,
and like,
thanks for holding me up
for a few minutes,
while your friend figures out
how to work a fucking camera.
I mean, that's the other ...
have you noticed the thing of
when people take pictures
after shows,
how rude some of the people
that ...
you want to like your fans,
and then they're so rude
to the guy taking pictures.
Who's not being paid to do it,
I mean,
except we're tipping them at
the end of the week or whatever.
They don't know that.
This person's
just taking pictures,
and they go, "It's blurry.
Do you not know
how to work an iPhone?"
And I go, "I hate you now,
and I don't want to take
a second picture."
So often, I think
a lot of people are assholes.
Oh, yeah.
It surprises me how many women,
it's usually women
that are like,
"I look disgusting in this.
Have you ever taken
a picture before?"
And hands it back to them. I go,
"Don't talk to him that way.
You're not paying him."
I push for selfies.
Selfies are so good.
When somebody walks up,
"Can I get a picture?"
I go, "If it's a selfie, yes."
Yes.
Let's do it.
Yeah, because then
you can see it. There's no-
If they're all shaky,
I just grab it
and do it myself, you know?
Dude, selfies.
I can't agree with you more.
People always shit on selfies,
like,
"Oh, are you taking a selfie?"
I'm like, it's the most
efficient way to take a picture.
What's the alternative?
Handing it to someone and
bothering someone to take it?
It's a better picture,
because it's this-
You're seeing it. Yes.
It's the faces.
You're selling the faces.
It's better.
Unless they're wearing like
a Dancing With the Stars outfit
or something,
you don't need the body.
I don't need the body.
People take pictures from so far
back,
and then cameras also still,
the camera phones like iPhones,
everything still looks further
away than it actually is.
Yeah.
You could be in the front row
at a concert
and want to post a picture,
and it looks like
you're sitting so far away.
Yeah, I was just at a basketball
game where that happened.
I was like,
"Look how close I am!"
It looks like I'm-
Then you try to use the zoom,
and you get a blurrier picture.
Yeah. It's so weird.
Oh, have you ever tried to take
a picture of a full moon?
Is there anything more
disappointing than a full-
So you are back
on the weed train.
Oh, yeah.
That is not a sober thought.
Either that, or you're
a werewolf with a hobby.
"Damn, I can't get a picture
of the full moon!
I don't have opposable thumbs!
Oh, my God.
Somebody take this for me.
Every time it happens.
I seriously ... yeah, selfies,
I am so on board
with selfies after shows.
It's so much quicker and easier,
and passing the phone off
to another person.
The person takes it, and it's a
phone they've never used before.
They've got to figure it out.
Then they go to go,
"One, two, three ..."
Just do it.
I always tell the guy,
just take it right away.
They also drill it.
Sometimes they'll drill it,
so they've got 12 pictures
of you with your eyes closed
and three with your eyes open.
Guess which one
they're going to use?
For me, the one where
I look the most stoned.
Of course.
Yes. They never tag you.
I take 1000 pictures a weekend
and two people tag me.
I go, "Why did you
even want this?"
I always tell people to, also.
I do too. Tag me.
Then they have to like,
look you up and stuff.
They never do it.
Oh, I was at the theater
yesterday,
and before the curtain came up,
this young couple, a man
and a woman came up to me.
She was like,
"Can we get a selfie with you?"
Sorry to bother you, I know
we're at the theater, whatever.
I'm like, "No problem."
So, I stand up
and we take a selfie.
Then this lady comes up.
"My daughter's mad at me,
because I want a picture too.
I don't know who you are,
but I want a picture
because she got one,
but now she's not
talking to me."
Snap, then she takes
the picture.
I watch her go back over
and sit near her daughter.
Her daughter's just like
refusing to speak to her.
Like, "Why do you have
to embarrass me like that?"
It's so funny that she needed
a picture,
and she doesn't know
who you are.
Yeah, "I don't know who you are,
but my daughter got a picture,
so I need one too."
Doug, if people want to get high
with you or get you high ...
because I think
that's a thing.
If you're a Doug Benson fan,
your dream is like,
"I want to smoke weed
with Doug Benson.
I want to get him high.
I want to roll him a-"
Isn't that a great rocket,
that that's people dream
to give me weed
and smoke with me?
Its their bucket list shit.
It's not an exaggeration.
It is a true dream
of potheads, to do that.
I've seen it happen,
and I can only imagine
it's gotten even more
so over the years.
What is the best way
for them to do that?
What is the most efficient way
for someone to get you high
and have an experience with you?
To not be annoying,
and to walk away
with you being like,
"Oh, that guy was a good guy."
Just be standing next to me,
is what I like to say.
If you want to get me
to smoke with you.
Unless we're like,
in an airport or something,
then we can't do it.
If I'm anywhere where we can
get away with it,
I'll smoke with anybody.
What kind of conversation
do you want to avoid?
What kind of questions have you
been asked too many times?
How can we make this experience
the best for you?
I want to hang.
I don't want to interview.
Yes.
When a fan comes up
and just starts asking ...
if they ask about
something specific,
like that I never hear about,
or that, "Oh yeah,
this is kind of a fun thing
to tell you the answer to."
That's fine,
but a lot of times it's just,
"Where you going next?"
They just, it's very generic.
I'm like, just go look
at my Twitter.
I talk about that all the time.
Let's have a real conversation.
I'm just up for ...
that's the great thing
about smoking pot too,
is that you can get
a bunch of fans at once.
We're all in a big circle,
and then I can say things
that make everybody laugh,
and they feel like they're
getting an extra performance.
It's a good time.
You're like the Bert
Kreisher of weed.
People like to drink with him
with his shirt off.
Doug likes to keep his coat on
and smoke weed
with his fans after shows.